all right should i have had this up on
friday yeah but what can i say i was i
was in kind of a rut just
you know i was 20 20
then i watched cobra kai and got the
pick-me-up i need to do this video and
the boys it's not that pick-me-up it's
great but it's not that kind of
pick-me-up cobra kai though yeah this is
also not a video on kobrakai
maybe soon though but all right episode
four of season two of the boys is hit so
now we talk about that so right it moves
forward in terms of revelation also
spoilers this is a spoiler video when i
talk about episodes
week to week there's no real way for me
to talk about it other than spoilers so
there that is and as we're in episode
four actually this is halfway through
season two now we're
halfway there so some things are now
happening
i feel like the crew the boys they're
being divided
not being divided in terms of tension
just they're kind of going their own way
which huey starlight that's her name
right i always want to call her starfire
and mother's milk whose name always
makes me think of homelander because of
that saying they're going their own way
trying to find out about this compound v
which mother's milk is great he's one of
my favorite characters in the show i
thought he was great in season one
but season two he really is the leader
the group needs right now point is i
like him
and then they come across as ladies like
yeah this super racist killed my brother
oh by the way that's super racist so our
super self-righteous
kale crunching friend from portland
oregon
is not so righteous she is a super
racist douchebag there's tension between
her and homelander that's growing
because homeland was like
i'm the face of the seven she's just
talking about branding like well you
gotta work on your brand
which is this is what i love the boys
that's why i love the boys there was
some weird double speak just a second
ago but bear with me
i've always felt like the boys was a
peek into the mindset of the
entertainment industry you have all
these self-righteous actors telling
people how to think
how to vote it's like but who are they
they don't know what the real struggles
of people are actually
like and odds are they're just chasing
that
clout for the sake of their image and
brand and the boys is one of those shows
that just kind of puts that
into that perspective like yeah this is
entertainment industry 101. so i
appreciate the boys for that and i feel
like
stormfront is it's another piece of that
puzzle black noir is cool though
i mean but he still seems like a
murderous [ __ ]
but he's kind of awesome maybe he's good
maybe he's bad maybe he has a gambling
problem i don't know anything about him
but
the fact that i know the least about him
is what makes him intriguing it also
makes
some good humorous moments i just like
the scenes with black noir in it whether
he's
just sitting next to an i.t person a
tech person and they're super nervous or
he just scoots someone over on the piano
and starts just killing it on the piano
it's like black noir but butcher is
where i start to get concerned with this
show because
butcher is i mean the warpath he was on
was for the sake of getting revenge for
his probably dead wife he was on that
war path for
years before we even met him we saw the
tip of the iceberg of that then the end
of the last season he finds out she's
alive and then the beginning of this
season
he's far away from there doesn't know
how he got away from there and now he's
like all right i gotta find her again
and now he finds her again and he
actually shows up
and talks with her that's a lot that
happened in a very quick amount of time
they could have spent the whole season
of butcher like
i gotta get back to within a really
quick amount of time it was like he was
there he was gone he was back he's
talking with her and she's pretty much
like all right i'm gonna go with you
we're gonna escape and she's like i
don't think i can go with you because i
don't think you would accept my kid
what she's right she's pretty much like
at a point you will try to get me to
drop him and he's like
you're not wrong but here's the thing
about it is
she says that you're a lot and the fact
that butcher's alive means
something happened with homelander in
that whole situation
i guess the situation is she was like if
you kill butcher i will kill myself
in front of the kid my son also
homelander
biologically speaking your son so the
reason that's weird to me is because
it's like when it comes to butcher and
the kid butcher wins
in the sense that well if butcher dies i
will kill myself in front of this kid
thus mentally [ __ ] him up forever
he will just have damage now and she's
fine with that but when it comes to
butcher and the kid when they leave the
facility
well the kid wins she doesn't want to go
out there with her
her kid and butcher in a world where
maybe butcher will try to get her to
choose butcher over him it was very
strange to me you could at least
leave and then cross that bridge when it
comes if butcher gets to know the kid
maybe butcher will be like well we gotta
protect the kid i actually do
like the kid and that could be some
growth with butcher maybe they'll
eventually do that but it's just weird
she's like no i'll just stay in this
super prison
why not i'll have homelander come and
terrorize us rather than just leaving
now
and i mean if butcher starts to be a
dick you can then
leave butcher also go off on your own
makes me a little nervous i hope they
know what to do with him now that his
entire reason for his war
path is basically not there right now
look i don't know what they're gonna do
with butcher but just
just don't joel him that's all i'm
saying i don't know i'm probably being
paranoid
but it's a paranoia that i feel like is
justified but it was a good next chapter
and i was hoping they would go an
interesting route with stormfront and
they really are but also we have to ask
ourselves
would you question for the philosophers
i suppose
all right so the boys episode four of
season two were halfway through what did
you think about it do you think they're
going in an interesting direction does
butcher's arc
kind of not freak you out but make you
nervous whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you